hi
everyone welcome to our talk uh feature
drift monitoring as a service
for machine learning models at scale my
name is kira joe
i am a data engineer at capital one
hi everyone my name is nori tatsuni i
work with kira
and i'm a director of engineering in
capital one's car technology division
before we dive into the details of the
system i'd like for us to get aligned
on a couple of terminologies the first
is feature
it's an overloaded term in software
engineering
but in machine learning it's a
descriptive attribute
that's used as an input to a machine
learning model to make some sort of
prediction
a feature drift is a change or shifting
a joint distribution
of a feature and a target what you see
on this slide
are a different types of feature drifts
it can be a distribution change in
values
or sometimes the associated labels
alternatively drift might be referred to
the relationship
between the feature values and the
labels
so because machine learning is learning
from data
or the features it's really important
that the features
are monitored especially for business
critical machine learning models
as a company you don't want to take a
risk on
not monitoring your features because
many models of brittle
and the impact may be that you incur a
significant financial loss or harm to
the brand of your business
this is why we built our feature
monitoring solution that's
accessible to any of our data scientists
and engineers in capital one
our service platform helps detect
features
through statistics and model based
matrix
the the metrics include descriptive
statistics like
mean and standard deviation
[Music]
um we have some data quality metrics
like
record count and number of now's to make
sure that the upstream data pipeline is
healthy
for our analysis service we have
population stability index or
we just call it psi psi is a
measure of how much a feature has
shifted over time or between two
different samples
we also offer a model based analysis for
time series change point and anomaly
detection
to to indicate
abrupt and significant changes
so our platform provides our users the
access to all these metrics
analysis through various interactive
interfaces like
visualization dashboards api
sql interface and alerts
with the capabilities that our platform
offers our users can continuously make
sure that
their models are performing well they
can use the interactive interfaces to
derive signals to retain a model
proactively make decisions on whether
they want to use a feature or not
or explain why their model has shifted
so to offer the services
or a service to multiple teams and
models
we need to make sure that our platform
is able to handle the scalability from
both functional and non-functional
requirements perspective
to achieve that we made these five key
design decisions
while building a platform the first
is that the features are pre-registered
in a feature catalog so that we can
identify them
and determine how to access them
we're also making sure that the features
are sorted in standardized format
so that we can read them easily
the second design decision was to have
our clients
or client users and applications
get their own access to the features
they want to monitor and provide that to
the platform so that
the platform doesn't have to have access
to massive volume of features in capital
one
this was definitely a challenging
problem to solve
but it was a top priority as a bank
the third decision is to enable our
users to specify their own
aggregation keys without this capability
to tailor our outputs
to the context that the model developers
are working with
the metrics and analysis that we produce
will likely be
completely useless
our fourth decision was to make sure
that we build a system in a way that our
users
aren't stepping on each other's toes by
incorporating
distributed processing techniques and
robust orchestration layer
and lastly because qualifying a feature
drift
is very specific to each model we
provide tools to visualize
slice and dice the metrics and analysis
that our produce
platform produces to empower users to
make their
own conclusion decisions on when and
what to do
with their models so next here and i
are going to double click on the
implementation details of these design
decisions
so the first thing we'll cover is the
data pipeline architecture
this is essentially what makes various
features discoverable
and readable to the feature monitoring
platform
so to my team's luck capital one has a
reliable and robust enterprise common
capability for data cataloging
data ingestion and persistent storage
that almost all applications use already
so with these services the feature
compute functions can calculate features
in
just in time streaming or batch fashion
and send the computer output to the
ingestion service
for the data to be persisted in rk files
with
file location partition keys
and schema available in the data catalog
service
the ingestion service can take average
messages from streaming
and just-in-time api services or whole
files from bad systems
thanks sorry so now i am going to talk
uh about the technical details of our
feature monitoring as a service
uh this is our architecture diagram so
we have a trigger api as an enter point
to our
monitoring service also the trigger api
connects to the air flow
and the spins up emr cluster that runs a
pi spark job
you know you may notice that we also
have a radius cluster
um the need for that is to cache our api
requests
so that we don't accidentally receive
like five
ten same requests and spins up too many
emr cluster
um the stats computation are done by
spark
emr and the output is sent to our
enterprise kafka cluster
our enterprise kafka has the capability
of save the results
into our enterprise aws s3
and also we have our own ingestion
engine that listens to
our stats topic and writes the output to
postgres
as a serving layer we provide a grafana
dashboard
as well as the graphql api the other
thing i want to point out is
we um we have external team that builds
machine learning as a service
we partner with them so they can use the
stats we produced
and run more advanced analysis and
algorithm on top of that
to do a feature drift detection
excited so
um yeah the first thing i'm going to
talk about is
our trigger api so it triggers and
configures our feature statistics
calculation
as nori mentioned that we have
enterprise feature registry
it provides every feature unique id
so we receive a data set location id
from our client
and use that to query our feature
registry api
and receive a list of feature id and
that information is used for us to
uniquely identify a given feature
along with their statistics we
calculated
so besides the data set location the
data set id
and feature ids there are a couple other
configuration we
asked the user to provide us first is
the temporary client credentials and
this is what as norway mentioned that we
don't want to have a universal
credential to have access to all our
data sets
so we take this temporary credential
from our client
to read their feature data set for our
stats computation job
um and it's like more secure that way so
that
um we don't um so we have like better
design um pattern so as we are
designing the whole process we realize
there are various
aspects of time for a given data set for
for example i have this um data set on
on the right hand side
let's say if we want to track someone's
biking exercise we want to track like
how far he he has gone and like what is
that elevation gain for
a biking trip so there's the concept of
event time meaning that when was that
biking trip occurred
and then there's also the concept of eto
time meaning
that when does that data set landed in
our system
so as a data engineer maybe i'm more
curious of future statistics based on
the etl time
and just to see if my etl process is
running correctly
of if there's any major change of the
process
but however as a data scientist maybe
i'm more interested in the
statistics that's aggregated based on
event time for example if i want to run
some analysis
for a given user and see like oh what's
the average
biking length for that user for the past
seven
or three months so because of that we
provide this additional field called
aggregation fields it lets us
lets the user configure on what field
they want
to use to produce these statistics
in that way our pipeline is a lot more
flexible of the statistic
statistics we're generating
so now i'm going to talk a little bit
more about
our stats calculation so our stats
calculation process is
running on emr and as norma mentioned
that right now we compute some
descriptive
statistics like mean max average and
some quantiles and counts
we also compute psi the population
stability index
just to kind of measure the distribution
between the two data sets
the default behavior of our pipeline
right now is to compare
the latest partition of a data set
versus the partition before
so all our processes are running on emr
and every individual request it has its
own emr
um in that way so there's like no
processes interfering with
each other and
also all the results are sent to our
enterprise kafka
and saved to our postgres database as
well as s3
one thing i want to mention that we also
have a unique job id
i didn't associate with every individual
um
stats calculation it's easier to
in that way it's easier for us to keep
track of um
the calculation process like how far the
process has run
and also it's easier for us to debug and
see like if
stat job has completed or not
so um next i'm going to talk a little
bit about our postgres table design
so we have two tables to keep track of
our
um statistic computation first is to
store the stats as
themselves and the other is to track the
job status
so for the feature stats table we store
every statistic as its own entry meaning
that
mean and max there's their separate
entry in this table
the reason we designed that is so that
we can have a more flexible
table schema and then if we want to add
a new statistic
into our system we don't have to change
the database schema again and again
um we also utilize this parent-child
table design so in the parent in the
parent table we only store the index of
the
child table and then the request is
actually directed to the child table and
all the data are saved in the child
table
we partition these tables based on the
feature name
just so that it's easier and faster when
users try to retrieve
their feature statistics and in our
job status table it tracks of like where
the process
has run so the trigger api the pi spark
job as well as our ingest
engine or all connect to this table and
update these table in real time
and one other thing i want to mention is
we have
a kubernetes cluster managed by a
different team
it's very easy to use they manage those
kubernetes clusters in aws
and they provide every team and every
project their own team name space and
also
a personal name space as a developer we
can just focus on how to develop our
application and then we can deploy them
into like dev qa and the pro environment
and we um as like our design our trigger
api ingestion
and graphql api all running on this
kubernetes cluster
in this way it's easier to manage them
and everything is all those scaled up
and down based on the request
and then every application is running
independently so they won't interfere
with each other
and one last thing i want to talk about
is our serving layer this is like where
the fun is
we provide the two major way of for
users to see their
statistics one is a dashboard and the
other is a graphql api
so i want to first talk about this
dashboard on the left hand side
we have a very specific use case our
client
has their data set uh partitioned by etl
time
and with each partition they keep a
whole history of their feature data
meaning that if they have 13 years of
data they keep that in every single
partition
this is like very specific for their use
case
when they're trying to calculate
statistics what they're interested
is they want to see the stats over
the time of like when the event actually
happened but they are also curious like
what if there's any major changes
between two partitions like
like how can they see them like faster
um
so because of that we provide this
panel for them they can see as as you
can see like the
stats themselves are plotted based on
the event time
and um we provide them the two panels
that
they can compare side by side for the
partition they choose
so the top panel is from the june
partition and the bottom is from the
main partition
so this is like a very like centralized
way for them to have a quick
view of their statistics as well as
their feature
the second interface we provide is the
graphql api
it's a more flexible way for user to
retrieve their feature stats as however
they want
for example if you want to see an
average for a given
feature for the past three months you
can just query our api get that data
back
and you can put that in the jupiter
notebook and then just plot them
in however way you want or even do
analysis on top of that
um as also as we mentioned earlier that
we partner with the external team
they also use these statistics we
generate to run feature drift detection
algorithm
on top of them
so as a conclusion these are our
five key design decisions together with
the solution we provided
first is the feature must be accessible
identifiable in rebo
so we have this standard time series
temp series ingestion pipeline
with the parquet output as well as the
standard
data set and the feature registry that
people can uniquely
identify data set in the future and the
second is we want to provide the maxim
maximum security ability so that we
don't have a universal
access to all the data set we take the
client's temporary credential
to access their feature only and the
third
is the aggregation attributes are
configured configurable
as we said that sometimes people want to
see
their feature stats aggregated based on
different time
aspects or even like more other fields
so we let them
configure based on their own use and
it's easier for them to
get analysis and statistics on top of um
those visualization
and also all our process are running
in a distributed way our pi spark is
separate as our
separated emr cluster as well as
our applications are running on the
managed kubernetes cluster
and lastly we want to empower users to
to derive their own conclusions and
decisions so we
provide the centralized quick view of
the dashboard of the stats that
generated
but they can also just get this
statistics from us
through our api and then run the
analysis that fits their use
so this is um a wrap for our talk
thank you so much for listening i'm
looking forward to meet you guys at
our live q a session
you